alors question comment améliorer le
pouvoir d'achat des français en pleine
flambée des prix de l'énergie on en
parle maintenant avec nos invités on
vous a aussi posé la question ce soir
sur le conte télégramme verte et
français leur de notre face à face
[Musique]
avec nous pour en parler ce soir deux
porte-paroles représentants de deux
candidats à la présidentielle de 2000 22
sur ce plateau françois cocq porte
parole d'arnaud montebourg bonsoir
françois cocq merci d'être avec nous à
vos côtés en skaï par un philippe
ballard porte parole du rassemblement
national dont soir philippe ballard
merci d'être avec nous on le disait en
introduction à ces annonces du
gouvernement attendue d'ici la fin de la
semaine sur les prix des carburants on a
hâte parce que effectivement les
l'équation n'est pas simple à résoudre
en attendant les candidats sont mous
dans la brèche je me propose tout
d'abord d'écouter cette déclaration de
marine le pen ce matin la candidate du
rassemblement national
il faut baisser la tva sur le carburant
le fioul le gaz l'électricité de 20 à 5
5 % parce que ce sont des produits de
première nécessité les français pourront
immédiatement respirer et voir leur
pouvoir d'achat augmenter
on a constante dans ses propositions
marine le pen qui avait déjà proposé la
baisse des sax philippe ballard ça y est
la question migratoire passe derrière le
pouvoir d'achat clairement vous êtes
haut niveau sur ces questions
rassemblement national non pas du tout
mais ce soir un sondage qui est sorti
d'ailleurs qui passe le pouvoir d'achat
en tête des préoccupations des
françaises et des français il ya ensuite
la sécurité la santé et l immigration
donc le pouvoir d'achat touche parce que
là dans les exemples que vous montrez on
voit que c'est c'est pas péjoratif ce
que je vais dire le petit peuple cette
france et urbaine cette france rurale
qui souffre qui est obligé prendre sa
voiture qui roule au diesel parce qu'on
leur a dit pendant des années rouler au
diesel c'était très bien et maintenant
il se retrouve le bec dans l'eau l'état
est en train de s'enrichir pendant que
les français se déplume donc c'est pas
possible ce n'est pas tolérable on va
raquer quand même le prix de l'essence
et 60% de taxes et c'est pour ça que
marine le pen propose de baisser la tva
de 20 à 5 5% sur l'essence comme sur le
gaz l'électricité et les produits de
première nécessité parce qu'on parle
beaucoup injuste type du carburant mais
il ya d'autres études qui nous montrent
que des français un tiers des français
commencent à réduire sans chauffe de son
chauffage par peur de ne pas pouvoir
payer la facture donc emmanuel macron
président du pouvoir d'achat ça fait
juste rire et un dernier chiffre avant
d'entamer le débat même si je pense que
sur la question des sentira peut-être
parce qu on a les mêmes propositions
mais dans le projet de loi de finances
il y a marqué que le pouvoir d'achat
sous ce quinquennat progressé de 8% et
vous rappeliez de sondages d'opinionway
60% des français estiment tout
simplement la verse effectivement
beaucoup de difficultés à faire un
diagnostic il faut bien dire françois
cocq assez rigoureux parce que chacun y
va de son étude ya les chiffres de
l'insee d'un côté les chiffres voilà
d'autres sources peut-être qu'on voit
aussi avec le prisme de ses opinions
politiques tout d'abord pour rebondir ce
que vient de dire si
les positions
sur ce diagnostic de pouvoir d'achat il
n'y aurait pas cette flambée des prix de
l'énergie
aujourd'hui clairement les français ont
pu gagner oui ou non pouvoir d'achat
mais non seulement il y à la flambée des
prix de l'énergie et que le gouvernement
n'at-il pas agi plus tôt quand même
j'entends que le gouvernement devrait
agir d'ici la fin de la semaine il
apparaît agit en amont et encore
aujourd'hui il prend le temps c'est à
dire que les prix flambent et pendant ce
temps monsieur macro de france et de bi
ajouté
quelle célérité quelle célérité ces gens
sont absolument dans le coup et ils sont
en phase avec les préoccupations des
français non tout cela n'est tout cela
n'est pas sérieux et comme comme c'est
évoquer aujourd'hui il ya des chiffres
différents sur la table d'un côté il ya
le chiffre des instituts économiques et
de leur côté il ya la propagande
gouvernementale
et il ne faut pas se tromper et les
français ne s'y trompent pas parce que
leur quotidien va vers ce que nous
disent
les différents les différents instituts
est pas ce que dit monsieur macron donc
la question est maintenant comment on
redonne des marges de manoeuvre aux
français qui sont totalement étranglé
par cette situation sur la question du
de l'essence effectivement le prix de
l'essence aujourd'hui où le prix du le
prix du gazole ses 44 % du produit et la
distribution et puis le reste c'est des
taxes alors il ya des gens qui ont agi
j'entendais michel edouard leclerc dire
que lui ben finalement il vendait à prix
coûtant le gouvernement je le constate
est encore à la traîne là dessus mais
sur les 56 % de taxes il ya ce qu'on
appelle ati cpe la taxe intérieure sur
la consommation des produits
énergétiques et puis à la tva il faut
savoir la tva et les sur l'essence et
elle est sûre la tei cpe c'est à dire
quel le taxe sur la taxe tout cela n'est
pas sérieux aujourd'hui sur un litre
d'essence il ya environ 27 % de 27
centimes pardon de taxes de tva si on
ramener la tva de 20 2 20% à 5 et demi
pour cent ça ferait gagner 20 centimes
par litre qu'on rendrai aux français et
finalement refait passer le prix de
l'essence à ce qu'il était au mois de
février tout ça est une mesure de bon
sens applicable immédiatement et qui
aurait déjà dû être appliqué en même
temps que le blocage des prix et une
fois encore on est en train d'attendre
monsieur macron vous êtes d'accord donc
sur ce diagnostic la baisse des taxes
philippe ballard beaucoup vous des gens
ont dit cet argument d'inégalités parce
que ça se pâment au rize finalement tous
les français n'ont pas les français les
plus défavorisés qu'est ce que vous leur
répondez
nous mais effectivement si on baisse la
tva de 20 5 points 5 % tout le monde en
bénéficiera en quelque sorte y compris
la personne qui fait son plein dans un
gros 4 4 et qui va prendre sa voiture
pour aller passer son week end à
deauville en venant de paris m'en
fallait y aller on est dans l'urgence on
est dans l'urgence il faut que le
gouvernement l'entende monsieur macron
est très gentil avec les formes et les
très dur avec les faibles et il le
montre encore une fois ce soir en
tergiversant alors on attend peut-être
la fin de la semaine un chèque alors un
chèque énergie c'est existe déjà mais il
faut avoir quand même quelques chiffres
en tête pour en bénéficier il faut
gagner
1500 euros par an c'est-à-dire fooding
et en gros euros par mois parce on se
moque du monde donc tout ça n'est pas
sérieux et puis après parce que là on
est dans les mesures d'urgence mais il
ya des mesures quand même de long terme
on nous a vendu la mondialisation
heureuse qui s'est transformée en un
véritable cauchemar pour des millions de
françaises et de français
il y à une étude de la bce la banque
centrale européenne ça vient pas du
rassemblement national qui est sorti il
ya quelques jours et qui affirme que le
salaire médian ce qui est vrai en france
ce serveur médian c'est à dire la moitié
gagnent plus et la moitié gagnent moins
ses 1800 euros par mois vous entendez
bien 1800 euros pour la moitié des
salariés et l'explication c'est que la
france s'est désindustrialisée
voilà on a ruiné les français emmanuel
macron n'est pas le seul responsable
il faut revoir complètement notre schéma
économie relocalisée on va enclencher un
cercle vertueux les entreprises
embaucheront elles investiront elles
pourront augmenter les salaires il
confiera avec cette femme de la
mondialisation heureuse et de ses
accords de libre échange qui ruine une
grande partie des françaises et des
français dont une petite partie qui
n'ont profité justement à dans le
pendant de votre réaction philippe
ballard les premiers messages de nos
téléspectateurs sur telegrah verte et
françois sandrine être dit hausse du
smic et des salaires que les riches
partage au lieu d'aller planquer leur
argent dans les paradis fiscaux au
retour de riise f1 sur cette question de
l'augmentation des salaires d'une part
françois cocq et du fait que certains
profiteraient beaucoup plus que d'autres
votre réponse
bien sûr bien sûr le pont dont
d'aujourd'hui de ce qu'il faut faire et
ce qu'il faut mettre en place comme
comme mesure immédiate c'est de mettre
en place des mesures structurelles on
voit bien que dans la société il ya
besoin d'un rattrapage depuis déjà des
années les salariés se font tondre donc
aujourd'hui il faut qu'il y ait un
rattrapage sur la question des salaires
c'est-à-dire 10% d'augmentation
immédiate du smic et on ouvre un grand
grenelle des salaires où on augmente
tous les salaires en dessous de 2000
euros avec des discussions par branche
voilà ce qu'il faut faire voilà comment
on en donne et il faut redonner un petit
peu
d'abord de dignité au travail parce que
les gens vivent par leur travail et ils
sont fiers de cela il faut le leur
rendre aussi avec un salaire qui est qui
qui sont un peu digne et non pas comme
il est aujourd'hui à la baisse depuis
des années je les vois requis baisse
puisque vous aurez noté que la petite
inflation qui reprend est supérieur aux
maigres augmentations de salaires qui
ont été accordés aux français c'est un
débat philippe ballard vous avez l'air
dtc mais voilà ce cette question
d'augmentation des je vous fais
peut-être dire ce que vous ne vouliez
pas dire moi je vais vous donner la
parole sur cette question évidemment
l'augmentation des salaires et notamment
du smic on sait que beaucoup
d'économistes met en garde justement
contre cette augmentation
sur l'emploi votre avis au rassemblement
national vous augmentez également les
salaires comme celle de mambo non non
non on est notre logique
notre slogan c'est rendons leur argent
au fond c'est pour rendre leur pays
également mais nous ne sommes pas pour
des augmentations de salaire de l'ordre
entendaient 10% enfin on côtoie
quasiment quotidiennement des déchets
d'entreprise des pme qui ont bu trois
quatre salariés c'est tout simplement
impossible ils sont mais juste la tête
hors de l'eau donc nous on a eu notre
logis au contraire il ya 11 ans a bien
quelques jours souvenez-vous doit alors
on pourra parler des branches
effectivement en tension je pense de la
restauration hôtellerie ou là à part
augmenter les salaires et améliorer les
conditions de travail avec des accords
de branche je pense qu'on ne pourra pas
l'animal a regretté
voilà je pense à la restauration
l'hôtellerie c'est pas possible il ya
deux services trois services on n'a pas
le temps de rentrer chez soi on est payé
au smic
on a des horaires à rallonge donc là
effectivement dans certains secteurs il
faudra qu'il y ait des augmentations de
salaires après pour l'ensemble si on
raisonne d'un point de vue à
microéconomique nom au micro et macro
d'ailleurs économique on peut pas
augmenter les salaires comme ça nous on
a une autre logique dont on veut baisser
la tva présente sur les carburants sur
le gaz l'électricité on parle aussi
d'une baisse une annulation même de la
redevance les dunes privé d'une
nationalisation par dans des concessions
automobiles tout ça ça rend au fil de
l'eau du pouvoir d'achat aux français et
par ailleurs on fera des économies marie
le pen a commencé à présenter son
programme avec une grande partie sur
l'immigration puisque les allocations
familiales seront réservées aux français
pour bénéficier de toutes ces
allocations de solidarité comme le rsa
ou les allocations logement il faudra
avoir pour un étranger de travailler
cinq ans à taux plein quand vous
souhaitez en france tous à ces 16
milliards puisque 1 milliard liée à la
fraude fiscale et sociale entre 15 et 45
milliards selon les rapports
parlementaires voyez il ya un peu de
grain à moudre et puis on parlait de ses
factures d'électricité ou on empile les
taxes sur les taxes sont intacts sur les
taxes notamment les taxes pour les
énergies renouvelables
les éoliennes notamment ses 7 milliards
au total là aussi il ya des économies à
faire donc on n'oblige pas à augmenter
les salaires sauf dans certaines
branches mais on redonne de l'argent aux
français par un autre biais françois
qu'aucun rassemblement national on tente
de nous expliquer en tout cas que cet
argent on le récupère d'une certaine
manière chez vous comment on finance
toutes ces hausses de salaires justement
d'abord on finance en allant chercher
l'argent chez ceux qui en ont le plus
profité tous les ans 4,1 milliards
d'euros disparaissent parce que monsieur
macron a fait un cadeau à ses amis qui
est la suppression de liesse est donc il
est urgent de rétablir lisf pour
commencer deuxièmement les entreprises
aujourd'hui enjoint les fier également
bon il faut commencer par établir lisf
et ensuite on a bien vu les fausses
réformes qui ont été tirés qui ont été
mises en place et qui de et qui devront
donc être derrière détricoter
deuxièmement les entreprises disent
elles mêmes qu'elles ont des marges sur
les salaires et qu'elles ressentent le
besoin aussi de rémunérer leurs salariés
pour faire vivre le collectif humain
qu'est une entreprise
il ne faut pas avoir cette vision
dogmatique qui est de dire à ces pauvres
aux entreprises aujourd'hui qu'ils ont
le couteau sous la gorge non elles font
vivre un collectif humain et le savent
que leurs salariés ont besoin d'être
rémunérés et ça ça veut dire qu on
augmente les salaires mais aussi on met
en place une fiscalité juste parlem pour
redistributif sur le revenu et c'est là
l'un des principaux des accords que nous
avons avec le rassemblement national
nous sommes pour plus de justice fiscale
c'est à dire que chacun 10 oc et prenne
sa part dans l'effort national au regard
de ce qu'est son salaire et son et sont
revenus il ya des choses à mettre en
place et de ce point de vue là il ya
beaucoup de verticalité qui a été mise
en place avec monsieur macro ceux qui
s'en tire le mieux ce sont ceux qui sont
en haut de l'échelle eh bien il faut
inverser aujourd'hui son rapport de
force vous invite à découvrir en même
temps que moi en fait ce message
augmenté denis côté augmenter les
salaires plus réformé le système de
solidarité français en baissant les
charges les entreprises et planifier une
fin du système actuel car il n'est pas
soutenable démographiquement et
économiquement vous vous adhérez
philippe ballard à cette proposition
il ya beaucoup de choses j'aurais juste
revenir un instant sur ce qui ce qui a
été dit par le porte parole de monsieur
montebourg non la fiscalité fassi vous
parlez des gaffes à nourrir leur torde
le bras donc on n'est pas tendre avec
les gaffes à des multinationales qui
font l'optimisation fiscale puisque
malheureusement l'optimisation c'est
légal des techniques financières qui
sont moralement condamnable donc voilà
je voulais juste rectifier ce point et
après dans la réflexion de l'autre
téléspectateurs il y avait 1 où il y
avait des démographies effectivement
il ya un hiver démographique
en europe et il faut qu'on s'en
préoccupe il y à une proposition qui a
été formulée par marine le pen y en a
même deux c'est d'une part concernant le
quotient canton à deuxième enfant il
faut que ça soit une part entière et
puis on souhaite proposer pour les
couples une somme d'argent plusieurs
dizaines de milliers d'euros pour
s'installer dans la vie qu'ils
remboursent un taux d'intérêt
extrêmement bas et qui s'éteint à la
naissance du troisième enfant cette
question de la démographie elle est
rarement soulevée mais elle est
fondamentale d'autant plus que l'autre
côté de la méditerranée et là c'est pas
un hiver démographique mais c'est un
coup de chaud des biographies françois
cocq sans cette question la démographie
vont trouver aussi qu'on n'en parle pas
assez
des clés peut-être de votre question
c'est l'une des clés mais la clé
aujourd'hui c'est de permettre aux gens
qui sont en situation de vivre bien de
vivre dignement il faut aussi se
préoccuper de ceux qui sont aujourd'hui
en place c'est ça qu'on ne fait pas
assez aujourd'hui à partir du moment où
on a remis le pays au travail où on a
reconstruit la france on a recréé une
dynamique vertueuse henry
industrialisant en sortant de cette
mondialisation folle où on pas
reproduire à l'autre bout du monde des
produits nécessaires dont on a besoin
sur place et qui nous et qui nous
donnerait notre colonie on sait qu'on
trop cher en france
pas trop cher en france simplement des
règles qui sont totalement absurdes où
on privilégie ce qui a été fabriqué à
dix mille kilomètres plutôt que de le
faire chez nous monsieur macron a dit il
ya 18 mois qu'il fallait refaire une
filière de masques en france et
aujourd'hui il n'est pas capable de dire
aux collectivités territoriales de
commander leurs masques dans les
entreprises françaises il préfère leur
dire d'aller commander en chine tout ça
est absurde ces gens
ces gens sont des libres mondialisateurs
y pense que il n'ya que la règle du
commerce qui fonctionne tout ça n'a pas
de sens aujourd'hui à un moment donné
nous sommes à un moment paradigmatique
où il faut repenser l'état de la société
la manière dont on veut vivre c'est ça
que le coc ville nous a mis sous les
yeux et c'est ça que monsieur macro et
ses sbires sont incapables de lire et de
voir s'il bat largement le mot de la fin
on y arrive déjà mais malheureusement on
n'a pas tiré justement assez
d'enseignement il ya eu ce plan 2030 qui
pourtant temps d'être une réponse assez
problématique c'est n'est pas suffisant
de la démagogie pour vous à six mois de
la présidence
je relisais l'allocution télévisée des
menus macron du 12 mars 2020 dans
laquelle il nous annonce et le
confinement il s'interrogeait je vous
invite d'ailleurs à la relire c'est très
intéressant sur les s'interroger est ce
qu'on n'est pas allé trop loin dans la
mondialisation
oui évidemment et il nous disait vous
pouvez relire c'est noir sur blanc il
faut retrouver notre souveraineté quel
beau mot sanitaire notre souveraineté
alimentaire et on al'impression c'était
il ya un an et demi mais qu'on a oublié
tout ça comment oublier d'ailleurs
les gilets jaunes donc nous on est pour
le localisme produisent en favorisant
les circuits courts j'entendais monsieur
club parler des masques il faut savoir
que 97% des masques achetés en ce moment
commande publique ces masques sont
achetées à l'étranger
un an et demi après le début du
confinement on a tout oublié c'est
pathétique je pense que ce gouvernement
expédiant dans la publique n'obtient
rien à faire à l'elysée
d'avoir été avec nous en direct sur rt
france ce soir